retired former pope benedict xvi has
admitted he made a false statement
during an investigation into sexual
abuse in the german catholic church
benedict had previously previously said
he did not attend a meeting in 1980 at
which the transfer of a pedophile priest
to his diocese was discussed the former
pope says he made the false statement
due to what he now calls an editing
oversight a report released last week
found that benedict who was then
cardinal joseph ratzinger knowingly
failed to act against four priests
accused of child sex abuse in the 1980s
we can speak now to our religious
affairs analyst martin gock for more on
this story good evening martin how
significant is this admission from the
former pope
well i mean it's it's it's very
significant obviously i mean this is
it's really quite quite shocking um
what we have is basically that mission
not only of life but that mission of a
lie concerning um
priests that were actually actively
engaged in sexually abusing
uh children so
you know this goes obviously
very very serious questions which go i
think at this point way beyond the
church itself
what might happen to benedict and other
church leaders involved
well in the content of the church in the
context of the church itself is really
very unlikely that anything will happen
to benedict i mean he's an emeritus pope
he's very old
and he's retired and he is essentially
once again the very top he has been the
very at the very top of the organization
uh the question however uh
is whether prosecution would actually
direct their sides to
benedict we know that there are 40
people there about that are being
looked
into or their case are being looked into
by the prosecution
but sort of in you know the immediate
answer to that is really that very
likely nothing will happen to benedict
you know this big admission as you said
coming off the back of the report that
was just released last week about the
church in these cases of sex abuse in
the 80s
could this lead to any form of justice
for the victims
i mean
you know we cannot go on much more than
opinion and precedent really uh so far
what we have seen is sort of you know
repeated apologies from church members
we have seen different ways in which you
know the states i mean in this case
germany have attempted to look
uh
into cases that for a very long time
they clearly had not actually taken
seriously enough
but you know the question of redress uh
i think it's it's really no different
than it was a week ago before we found
out that that ratzinger uh you know had
had lied about the cases keep in mind
that there are
you know
sort of about 500 cases contemplated
within this within this report and
really i mean it's not
any bigger smaller than previous reports
the only one major difference
we do know now
is that
you know
essentially misconduct which is one of
what the lawyers in the case called it
went all the way to what then became the
top of the catholic church our religious
affairs analyst martin gac good to talk
to you
good stuff to you too
you